DANIEL FRIEDMAN (Speaker A): Hello everyone. We're in Active
Inference livestream number 50.1 on
October 20, 2022.
We're discussing the paper "Interception
as Modeling, Allostasis as Control."
Welcome to the Active Inference
Institute. We're a participatory
online institute that is communicating,
learning and practicing applied Active
Inference. This is recorded in an
archived livestream, so please provide
feedback so we can improve our work.
All backgrounds and perspectives are
welcome and we'll be following video
etiquette for Live streams. Head over to
activeinference.org to learn more about
how to get involved with different
learning groups and projects like the
Live Streams and otherwise.
We're here in livestream number 50 point 1 with
our second discussion of the paper
"Interoception as Modeling, Allostasis as
Control." Previously we had number 50 point 0
where Dean and I provided some
background and context. And now we're
really appreciative that we'll have some
authors joining for the Dot One and Two to
unpack and explore some ideas.
And today it will be great to hear from
multiple authors, see a little
presentation and dive into the middle of
things, the thick of things, as we do in
the dot one. And so we'll begin with
introductions, then we will have a
presentation and then discussion. So
we'll begin with introductions with
non-authors first and they can feel
free to introduce, say hi and anything
that they're excited to explore today.
So, I'm Daniel, I'm a researcher in
California and I'm looking forward
to understanding some of the formalisms
in the model and how they connect to
active inference and Bayesian mechanics.
And I'll pass to Dave.
DAVE DOUGLASS: Hi, I'm Dave. I'm a
discourse curator and a student of [the late] Jaak
Panksepp and Mark Solms. I live in the
mile-high academic city of Baguio,
200 km north of Manila. Dean!
DEAN (Speaker C): Thanks, David. I'm Dean.
I'm in Calgary. What's interesting
to me is that on a metaphorical
level, this started out me in an open
field and I got into a forest and that
forest got denser and denser! By the
time I got to section four of this
paper, I started reading it over and
over again, which is a fantastic sign
because if I have to read something
many, many times to really get my head
around it, that's good - because
I don't question things unless I don't
get them. That doesn't mean that it
wasn't spelled out correctly, it just
means that you got my attention. So I'm
not sure which author to pass it to
first. Maybe. Eli, you'd like to say hi.
ELI SENNESH (Speaker B): Hello everyone, I'm Eli, I'm the first
author on this paper. So a
bit before the live stream started,
Jordan was mentioning that this work
comes out of what we were sort of
studying together in our lab at an
energetics working group, brain
energetics reading group before the
pandemic really did us. And so when I
was confined,
you know, I effectively started reading
and re-reading everything that we have
gone through and trying to come up with
some way to think about allostasis.
Because in our group and in our previous
publications as a group, the
Interdisciplinary Effective Science Lab,
we've referenced allostasis a lot. And
every time I would ask, how can we give
a mathematical and computational
characterization of allostasis,
I would basically be told, well, we
thought Peter Sterling had one. And then
I would go look at Peter Sterling, and
he's the originator of the concept of
Allostasis, by the way. So there's
numerous works by him on the subject.
Probably the longest form,
let's say nonexpert treatment,
would probably be his book "What is
Health?"
And when I would look at Sterling's
work, I would sort of spot a
contradiction or a contradiction in
terms. On one side,
he's specifically charting the variation
in physiological parameters and
regulation over time, where time
can be the course of a lifetime, the
course of development, or even just the
course of a single day. And yet, on the
other hand, if you ask him, well, how is
this done? He would effectively say "this
is done by reinforcement learning via
the dopaminergic systems in the brain."
Now, the dopaminergic systems in the
brain don't track a shifting signal
over time. They just maximize reward.
And so actually, in my view, at least, as
a computationalist, they were more
homeostatic than allostatic.
And from that contradiction and what
followed on from it really came this
whole paper. But to
re-emphasize, I would say, and before
we jump into slides material inside the
paper, I think it's really worth
emphasizing, just based on watching the
50.0 livestream, that our
group are more, let's say,
biologists and physiologists in
orientation than physicists.
So Bayesian, the paper on "Bayesian
Mechanics" came out while we were writing
this, and I
don't think we really managed to
integrate the two sets of material yet
together, or together yet.
That's not to say they can't or
shouldn't be integrated. It's to say we
don't actually have, so to speak, we
don't always have the physics and
dynamical systems expertise of someone
like Thomas Parr or Maxwell Ramstead,
let alone Karl Friston. On the other
hand, we have very concrete notions
of what biology and physiology we need
to fit to.
And really, the bulk of this paper,
the reason it's not just a short Section
Four with some math, is because we have
to fit to the physiology and the anatomy
that we know about.
FRIEDMAN: Thank you! Jordan, feel free to intro
and then, Eli, off to you for some presentation.
JORDAN THERIAULT: For sure. I'm a postdoc
in the lab here, so I think maybe I'll
just get some context of where we're
both working too, and how it got here.
So for me, I've had a bit of a weird
path to get to this point in that I did
my PhD in social psychology and moral
psychology, then sort
of got really, really interested in
predictive processing perspectives and
active inference and then really wanted
to dig into that and find someone who's
working on it around here in boston.
So I'm working with Lisa Feldman,
Barrett and Karen Quickly, who co direct
the interdisciplinary Affect of Sciences
lab here. And like you guys saying, the
perspective that we have is really more
of a biologically grounded one or more
of one that's based in physiology and
neuroscience. So Lisa and Carol joke
that Lisa sort of handles everything
from the neck up and Karen handles
everything from the neck down, so
together they form a whole person.
And what I was really lucky to do was I
stumbled into an existing collaboration
that's been going on for about a decade
here, which we called the Psychology
Engineering Neuroscience Group, or the
Penn Group, where there's been an
ongoing collaboration with professors in
the electrical engineering department.
Probably most importantly, Dana Brooks
has really helped run it a lot, that
Dennis Dogmas and Jennifer D have both
also been really involved in this.
And so what they would do is they'd meet
every week and they would sort of pour
through active interest papers,
predictive processing papers,
information theory. They'd sort of catch
all of us neuroscientists up to speed on
understanding engineering, and we try to
bring them up to speed on a sort of
biological understanding of
neuroscience, too. So what
we've been really interested in doing is
thinking about some of the abstractions
that had come up in the active inference
literature and thinking about how to
ground those biological processes and
how to really make this tractable at an
empirical biological level. And so the
interest that I've had in brain
energetics has been a way to apply
some of that traction onto my original
interest, which is sort of moral and
social norms. So I've done a bit of work
on thinking about how we can think about
energetic costs of information
processing as a way of how individuals
exercise control over a social
environment by conforming to
expectations within it. And then at
the same time, I've been interested in
going into the other end and thinking
about some of the details of brain
metabolism and brain glucose metabolism
that are associated with the Bold MRI
signal so that we can really dig down
deeper into the metabolism of the
thunderblind neuroimaging literature.
But in the process of basically forming
this energetic reading group where we've
been digging into all of those topics to
try to understand the brain biology.
Eli and I really ended up working
together in this paper to try to apply
some of that energetics and biological
work again. With a ton of help from
Karen and Lisa. Who really know the
details of the neuroscience and the
actual physiology. I think Karen
especially. That Eli would probably say
has been really critical
for understanding these physiological
systems. But basically. Yeah. How we
can have some of the parameters and
assumptions of these active inference
models grounded in real biological terms
so that we can start to look to the
empirical literature. The biological
literature. And sort of gain some more
inspiration from that rather than just
living entirely at an abstract level.
Cool. And with that, I'll hand it over
to you. Excellent. All right,
I've unsure. Feel free to go for it.
Thanks for that context.
And just a note, this paper
does bring in some topics that we
haven't discussed on any of the
preceding 50 papers, many of
which were also motivators of what you
set out to explore. So I'll just crop
and resize and so on. And Eli, please go for it.
ELI SENNESH: All right.
So before I really get into the material
of the paper. I think it might be useful
to follow on from what Jordan said in
order to additionally motivate sort of
our turn towards biology and physiology
here. Which is that most of the time in
active inference modeling note that I
say modeling or inactive inference
physics. So to speak. You need a term
in your expected free energy or in your
joint density. That is sorry, the
generative joint density, not the
recognition one, which you would call
often. I've heard it called the prior
preferences, essentially a probability
density over sensory outcomes. That
describes what hard to
avoid entropomorphic language here. But
well, what you want to observe now
in real biological systems that as
we sort of can hear from Peter Sterling
or numerous other authors, that cannot
be fixed.
That is, prior preferences can't be
fixed. I prefer different observations
when I'm about to go to sleep versus
when I am waking up.
And the assumption that usually gets
baked into principles
like, say, the free energy principle is
that actually, let me moderate that
a little bit based on conversations with
some free energy principle folks, if you
have a nonpath based, a state based
formulation of the free energy
principle, then you will typically
assume something called arrogate
ergodicity. And you'll note that we have
an appendix about ergodicity. I saw that
you discussed it last week in the .0
episode. Thank you for catching on to
that and thank you to anyone in the
audience and the listenership who caught
onto that. The ergodicity assumption
essentially allows you to exchange
uncertainty about time or over
time for uncertainty in the moment. So
you can just say there's gaussian prior
preference density. It has this much
precision or this much variance,
depending on which way you prefer to put
your division sign. And then it's
the same for all time. Now, if you're
doing a path space formulation, then you
lose the tie between the free energy
principle and conventional physiological
notions of homeostasis. Because now,
after all, can't the set point be
anything or everything? You need to know
something about physiology, anatomy to
tie it back. And so that's really the
motivation we're coming from in this
paper, is what if you have to acquire or
learn prior preferences throughout
development? How little can you bake
it?
And so we start by sort of reviewing
in the paper and in these slides, the
sort of perspectives that we study from
study the nervous system, study the
brain. One of them is predictive
processing. I think that's probably
going to be the important one for this
audience. And in predictive processing,
we talk about the perceptual systems of
the brain, really the sensory systems,
as performing approximate Bayesian
inference. So then you'll have top down
prediction signals, bottom up prediction
error signals. And there's
this notion of active inference which
says that we essentially treat motor
outputs as parameters to the
recognition model in one of its in one
of the earliest formulations before
there was any expected free energy. But
ultimately, it still says in any new or
recent formulation, we have some notion
of prediction error between densities
and this is an information theoretic
quantity. So really, we're talking about
a divergence or an entropy or a cross
entropy. We want to minimize that. And
we're not only going to minimize that by
changing the top down predictions that
flow through, say, the sensory cortex.
We're also going to change these extra
parameters that correspond to motor
motor predictions, motor commands,
motor references, depending on the
terminology you want to use to refer to
them. So then in our lab,
where we are sort of biologists of
emotion, we often study interoception.
And that's really it's given a fairly
vague definition on the slide here
because there's a lot of debate among
their own atomists about sort of where
interception ends and exter
exteroception begins, which exact
modalities should be classified, which
way or another. But really,
interception is still a set
of or category of sensory modalities.
And when I say sensory modalities, I am
mentioning that specifically because the
literature on interceptive active
inference then tends to take what
we might call the
earliest form of active inference.
It takes the road of the earliest form
of active inference, saying, I have a
generative density. I have a recognition
density. Action becomes effectively a
parameter to fit the recognition density
to the generative density. And there
isn't really a notion of an internal
generative model that is
separate that separates belief and
desire. So in a lot of the literature on
interceptive active inference,
you'll find references to having very
precise priors or even innate
priors about interceptive parameters.
And you'll see this notion that you
use active inference in the
interoception domain more than you use
it in the somatic domain because you're
trying to fit your internal physiology
to a notion of apriori
setpoints that are determined by
evolution. Do you think
you could give an example of that, eli
what sort of set points people might
think are innate?
Speaker B: Let's see, I've seen carbon dioxide
levels in the blood mentioned, glucose
levels. Core body temperature is really
the one that I tend to go back to
because it really does remain constant
most of the time. It can vary,
but really, that's an inextremis type of
situation.
So if you think about core body
temperature. There's a circuit
in, I believe, Jordan, correct me if I'm
wrong, but this is the NTS again, isn't
it? The nucleus solitarius.
Okay, yeah. Essentially in the brain
stem there's a circuit that codes the
typical set point for core body
temperature. And from an active
inference perspective, you could say
that is a fixed likelihood.
It can't be re parameterized by some
prediction flowing from higher up, or
rather, most of the time it is not
reparameterized. So that flows down
as a prediction. And then every
temperature sensor in the body can
compare actual temperature to desired
temperature, calculate a precision
weighted prediction error between them,
send those errors back up, and then the
brain can say, AHA, I need to find a way
to minimize these errors. And doing so
will effectively keep you in an
environment where you can maintain your
core body temperature around, you know,
I think it's 98.6 Fahrenheit is the
stereotype. It varies for individuals.
Now, the reason my next slide was about
allostasis is because while
there are bodily parameters like core
temperature that usually behave
according to a set point,
really physiologically most parameters
do not have a set point.
They move. The regulated levels move
all the time. So that includes heart
rate, blood pressure, blood sugar,
blood oxygen levels,
various hormone levels. In the endocrine
systems, inflammation levels shift
over time. And I mentioned inflammation
because from the body's perspective,
there is inflammation is not something
with a set point of zero. Inflammation
is sometimes appropriate. And actually,
if you want to think what is the
situation in which adapting all of these
core parameters is physiologically
adaptive, then I
think heavy exercise
and sickness are probably the two
largest examples. So for heavy
exercise, we could talk about, say,
arousal levels. And that refers to the
balance of cooperative activity in the
branches of the autonomic nervous
system. But essentially, if you're going
to go for a run, say from a
predator or after some food in
your good old fashioned evo psych
ancestral environment, you're going to
need to decrease the activity in some
organ systems, increase the activity in
other organ systems, and adjust
physiological parameters to be regulated
to the new levels.
So this is a pretty wellobserved fact of
physiology.
You know, informally, Peter Sterling,
I would say, having invented allostasis
as an observation that gets made, he
then editorializes a little bit about it
and says it should replace homeostasis
as a mode of regulation. So rather than
having set points, you should be
comparing to something like a set
trajectory. And in the ideal
case, when you're theorizing, you should
assume that there is no global set point
of any parameter. And of course, as we
mentioned before, in extremists this is
true if you get ill, your body does
actually override that circuit in the
brain stem to raise the core
temperature. That's why you'll get
chills. You're at the same temperature.
But the regulated level has been shifted
up.
Speaker C: There's also an interesting point to
make if you go back for one secular just
that in the way that the sort of
language of science evolves here too,
it's worth pointing out because some
people might be listening and might be
thinking, well, homeostasis doesn't have
to include set point either. You can
have sort of hierarchical notion of
homeostasis. You can have sort of
multiple levels of control involved in
that. And some people made the same
criticism of allostasis as an ocean. So
there's a paper by Carpenter,
there's a paper we cite by Carpenter
that does exactly this, right?
But the problem is that even if that's
like, that's technically true, and
people who really know what they're
doing and are using the concept of
homeostasis in that way might already
understand that you don't necessarily
need set points. But the
reality is that the way allostasis tends
to get used in the way that it tends to
be understood is it's come to have some
of this association with set plant or
with the simple thermostat model, as
opposed to something broader that
includes multiple levels of control.
And so some
people might be curmudgeony and want to
say that homeostasis already includes
all of these notions, so we should just
reclaim the term homeostasis for that.
I think we're more of the perspective
that we're willing to just give that up,
and it might be time to just start using
a different term to remind people of
those other associations. So we're
seeding ground a little bit when we're
using the term allostasis to just
not have to fight with people about what
allostasis really means.
Speaker B: Yes, so Jordan is completely correct
there, but I would actually even
recommend that everyone listening
if you can go find the paper,
Homeostasis a Plea for a Unified
Approach by RHS. Carpenter. It's in our
citations, and you should be able to
type the name into Google Scholar. Go
look at it, because it'll really explain
where our paper is coming from.
As a short summary of what's relevant.
What Carpenter says in his paper is that
back in the good old days, they taught
control theory and controls engineering
to physiologists, and that included
research physiologists and also
clinicians. And by back in the day, he
really means back in like the 1940s to
the 1960s, before another new approach
took over. And she says, hey, if you're
an educated, mathematically mature
and fluent controls engineer,
then you don't need, you know, then
these awkward names are all
really just different ways of cutting
the same cake. It's all a control
system. It's a hierarchical control
system. This is very evident, he says,
in the anatomy and physiology that
you'll look at. He's even writing for a
physiology education journal.
And then he effectively starts
complaining that everyone sort of
strawman homeostasis down to this
thermostat model.
And he has to complain like this in 2004
because indeed, everyone really has sort
of associated the word Homeostasis with
this, thermostat model global set plant
things like body temperature rather than
blood glucose.
And as a result,
as a result, much of the actual control
theory got simplified away.
So even as someone who is housed in
a computer science department took a
class on reinforcement learning and can
work the equations of optimal control
theory. I was not introduced to the
concept of a reference signal as a time
varying function until
Carpenter. And that was actually pretty
revelatory for me. That rather than
having an error function whose
global minimum is fixed for all time.
You can have an error function that
measures the difference between your
actual trajectory and a desired
trajectory. You can do trajectory
tracking control when you have the
mathematics. So we could say
for our paper, for our purposes, if
homeostasis refers to this,
thermostat style point tracking control,
then allostasis refers to trajectory
tracking control.
So moving on a little bit and getting
back on the main track from our
perspectives informed by physiology and
anatomy and a little bit of Evodevo
interception, and allostasis have both
pretty well demonstrated themselves to
be really central to how the nervous
system is actually structured and
seemingly largely concerned with the
metabolism and efficient functioning of
the viscera. So for anyone who wants
citations for this, I think it's Jordan.
It would be Barrett. And who?
2015. Oh,
barrett and Simmons 2015 yes. Barrett
and simultaneous neuroscience paper.
Yeah. Nature Reviews neuroscience
interceptive predictions in the Brain
There's a more recent review written by
Karen Quigley, our other senior author
on the interception came out in 2021.
And so you can
really go check for yourself. And I
would advise it just how central
interoception and visceral regulation
are empirically to the nervous system.
You could possibly design a nervous
system for a robot that worked
differently, but the ones that evolved
are ubiquitously, centered on keeping
the internal Nilia of the body
efficient.
So yes.
Dan Pickles? Yeah. Do you mind if I have
a quick question here? Of course.
Speaker D: The two office here maybe can just
confirm that my parachute is packed
properly. That's what I'm basically
wanting to be comfortable with.
So just stepping back for a second in
that slide that you would just had up
there, the warp and the west here, the
kind of the weave that you guys were
working on on this paper was the stasis
and the interoception. Those were your
focal point. Right. And then you've
spent quite a bit in sort of prepping us
for the difference between the discreet
time aspect of what you're looking at
and the global capture rate because you
say we can't get fixed.
This is what I'm saying. I want to make
sure my shoot is packed properly. And
then you're talking about biology and
physiology. So just on that
great big am I going to go splat or am I
going to be able to land this relatively
softly? Can you maybe just
tell me whether or not that is in fact,
is it a comparison? Is it an
intersection? Are these things running
in parallel? How much of this is risk
management versus how much of this is
strategic?
Speaker B: I would think of it more as an
intersection. And when we're
specifically referring to quantities
like the global capture rate, those are
intended to be strategic rather than
risk management or epistemic value.
So specifically there there's a whole
book on this, let's say Vigor the
Neuroeconomics of Movement Control by
Reza Shadmir, and it chronicles in
very long form extensively the empirical
evidence that real
organisms will time average their
reward rate. So in order to move from
an episodic setting to a continual
control settling point, a continual
lifelong setting, you need some notion
of indefinite time control. Obviously,
you're not going to live until T reaches
infinity. But in the limit,
you do need to have a coherent control
problem, at least for modeling purposes,
because you can't fix the end of, say,
a bird's life in the lab on a laptop.
And there's two ways conventionally to
do that. One is this notion of the
global capture rate. So the time
average, the sum of all benefits minus
the sum of all costs divided by the
total amount of time, and the other is
exponential discounting.
Now, for engineering purposes,
exponential discounting makes the
mathematicians much more tractable.
And so in the early two thousands, they
essentially found that the real brains,
like basal ganglia and dopaminergic
firing are best fitted by time
averaging. And then on the computational
side, everyone ignored that and did
exponential discounting.
And so really, when we talk about
something like a global capture rate,
we're just saying we're going with the
biological evidence and writing down a
model that accounts best for the
empirical findings. If you want to,
quote, unquote, try this at home, you
are perfectly welcome to go ahead and
switch to exponential discounting. It's
fine. Or the machine learning community
is starting to come out with papers on
time averaging lately, the past
couple of years.
Speaker D: That's one more quick question then. Of
course. Yeah. Thank you for that
explanation. So if we're raising
the question around tractability, that
assumes that there's some sort of
slipperyness or some fluidity piece to
this thing that we're looking at.
What is that? What is that thing,
that's fluid, that's slippery, that's
causing us to not normally be able to
model? Is that a feature or is that a
flaw? I would say
the slippery no is the slip between map
and territory.
So when talking about real brains,
we know that we observe time averaging
in the territory. What we
don't know how to do is write an
algorithm that provably,
produces correct time averaging,
and works in practice and engineering.
So let's even say rather than map and
territory because the scientist has a
map as well, let's say the slippage
is between empirical science and
engineering.
And when we write out our model, we are
really trying to address the empirical
science. And we don't mind if engineers
want to make their little slippage and
use something that just makes the
algorithmics easier, that's fine.
And in fact, that is what the deep
active inference community does.
Okay, so heading back a little more
towards active inference when we
read all of this stuff, this is sort of
a bit of a bible for our lab, Sterling
and Loughlin. So Simon
Loughlin was involved in some of the
earliest publications on predictive
coding in the Fly retina. Peter Sterling
is the originator of the concept of
allostasis. And what we actually notice,
as mentioned a bit earlier, is this sort
of slippage, another slippage or
contradiction. So they say
when you get a reward, some dopamine is
released this invokes a reinforcement
learning principal algorithm.
Let's be careful with neural circuits
that we're not studying in detail for
the moment. That is, let's be careful
how strong a statement we make about
their function. And then most of the
empirical evidence they review in the
book is about the energy efficiency of
sensory firing.
So we're really trying to say we
want to move from something grounded
in minimizing a prediction error,
variational inference to something
grounded ideally with an optimality
principle in control.
So then there are some arguments for
neuroscientists which are more or
less intended to convince the viewing
neuroscientists that people studying
interception and people studying motor
neuroscience need to work together on
studying the visceral. You can't study
the visceral and ignore the motor branch
of the visceral nervous system and the
functions of that motor branch.
Now, regarding our statement of you
can't just minimize prediction error,
one might ask, what about active
inference? And there
we have to start being careful with the
term active inference because as
I have had it personally explained to me
at length, there are at least the two
different kinds of active inference.
There's this very old,
I think it was Adams 2013,
you know, motor active inference
predictions not commands active
inference in the motor in the motor
system. And then there's this
notion of decision active inference,
where you have an expected free energy,
explicit prior preferences, and so on
and so on. And if you talk to the active
inference community, read the papers
that they can write for their own
community. I would particularly
recommend the International Workshop on
Active Inference, which I believe is
gain to be a conference next year.
They have three years of very good
papers where many authors sketch out the
explicit connections between active
inference, control as inference,
optimal control,
etc. So really, when we bang on saying
don't use active inference to reduce
motor function to sensory function,
we're talking to some psychologists and
philosophers who have been,
let's say, quite enthusiastic about
predictive processing, but a bit
eliminative is about some of the
mathematical constructs that are
actually used in active. Inference.
So then for our psychologist audience,
we have once again the argument that we
are basically showing that you can
and should do a fully probabilistic
notion of optimal control in order
to sort out what is going on with
allostatic regulation. And we're going
to take some inspiration from motor
neuroanatomy in doing it.
So looking at a simple model system,
and this is getting into figures from
the paper, we have our Barrow reflex
exafferent response curve.
You have a kerated barrel receptor.
It's in the keratid artery in the neck.
It measures blood pressure projects
to a circuit in the NTS in
the brain stem.
And we bring this up here because the
barrel receptor is often used as a model
interceptor. When I talked to Karen and
asked for model systems of interception,
she actually said, well, let's think
about the barrel receptor first and
again with contradiction. What we
actually find, looking at the anatomy,
is that the barrel receptor, the caroted
barrel receptor, is the sensory branch
of a low level control circuit.
So the NTS will then have,
I believe, the middle inflection point
is coded in the NTS here and doesn't
really change much. But what does happen
is that you can get top down commands
flowing into the NTS and then changing
the gain of this circuit so the
slope of the curve, and if you
widen that slope so that the curve is
shallower, then you're preserving
responsiveness,
you're widening the approximately linear
portion of the curve while allowing for
the blood pressure to rise and fall.
And so again, we see for the
interception people that you really need
to think about what is the role of this
interceptor in control of the
body and of the visceral. You can't
just look at it and say it's a sensor.
Okay, it's a sensor. Where does it
project you? Interoception cortex?
No, no, not necessarily like, you know,
the error, the prediction error signals
that reach interceptive cortex to
say, you know, I can't pump enough blood
or something like that, might actually
have already been processed by what
I believe in the motor active inference
literature is called a reflex arc. So
there might already be a reflex
controller that has operated on that
signal by the time it reaches the higher
portions of the brain.
So in our paper, we set out some
vocabulary for people to use if they
want to, don't have to capacity curve
in particular, we're going to tie it to
the notion of a cumulative distribution
function later on.
There's some physiology terminology for
people who want to learn it. And then
we note the same thing that Carpenter
does, carpenter and a
number of other papers, which is that
this is a massively hierarchical
controls system.
Lots of regulated substances,
let's say, or regulated variables
are going to have multiple controllers
influencing them. So, for instance,
blood nutrient levels, not just glucose,
but I believe, like salt, fat,
water, are regulated
by pairs of hormones. Sometimes there
will be multiple pairs of hormones per
nutrient that has to be in the blood.
And this isn't a convex trade off. So
that's not antagonistic competitive
regulation. They can appear to compete
sometimes, but actually it's cooperative
regulation based on the fact
that, so to speak, chemical species
can't encode negative numbers the
way a digital signal can. So when you do
things with chemical signals, having
these pairs turns out to be the way to
monitor and control the dynamic range
with the greatest sensitivity.
So then, using this example of leucaena
and insulin, we can see that sort of
normal glycemia is really more of a
range. And it's a range where you're
going to have approximately linear
response of insulin activity
and you're going to have saturated out
or really you're going to have threshold
value glucagon activity. So at
a normal level of blood sugar, glucagon
does not have to retrieve additional
blood sugar from the intestines or the
liver. It doesn't have to call for
burning fat reserves.
Essentially, you've eaten enough for the
day, you're fine. Insulin is responsive
in a highly response curve where it can
give a linear response to a linear
change in order to compensate for noise.
So now we can actually get towards and
now that we have a controller way to
think about physiology, we can get more
towards these notions of active
inference. And here we're going to go
back to some of the sources that
gave us motor active inference. One way
to think about motor active inference is
the brain sends a prediction. The reflex
arc in the spinal cord attempts to
minimize prediction error by
comparing the prediction with the value
read off of appropriator.
So again, one way to think about that is
having a few extra ways to minimize
prediction error, really entropy.
Another way to think about that is to
think of having a very elementary
control system at the reflex arc level,
and then the brain prescribes the
reference length that is the reference
signal for that controller. And it just
tries to minimize the difference between
what it gets off Approprioceptor, what
it reads, the actual muscle length and
tension, and the reference signal.
And this is actually a very I'd almost
call it a fun circuit to study because
of just how well documented it is,
that there's something very much like,
I would almost say, like a precision
weighted pig controller in there.
If you're a math person, then a muscle
is kind of like a spring. A spring can
be the dynamics for a spring metal
spring, stretch it and crunch it can be
linearized around certain points.
And so you can just about write down an
LTI pit control error, a musk
for an individual muscle spindle,
and you'll get two parameters coming
down from the brain, one of which says
the reference length and the other of
which says, what's the sensitivity or
gain against perturbation? That you
should exercise. And this is actually
how your voluntary movements are
engaged. So really
all of this stuff about references that
we're talking about here is just putting
forward to the hypothesis that maybe
visceral motor control works on the same
computational and anatomical principles
as voluntary. somatomotor control.
Speaker D: Of course. Instead of the commands
coming down from say. somatomotor
cortex. They might be coming from
ganglia in the autonomic nervous system
with the higher level central nervous
system basically just prescribing rough
levels of activity activation
or deactivation for the two different
sides of the autonomic nervous system.
Which then again in this opponent
fashion. Semioponant fully cooperative
fashion. Allow us to avoid encoding
digital negative numbers and thereby
give you very finely balanced control
over the internal mileage.
So we eventually get to our figure which
essentially says if I know what resource
supplies. Metabolic resource supplies.
Nutrients. Oxygen. Carbon dioxide. That
sort of thing I'm going to have
in the future. Then my goal is
going to be. Let's not say to
maximize uncertainty. Nor to minimize
uncertainty. But really to maximize
resilience or freedom to
stay in the linear portion of a
cumulative distribution function where
you can be responsive to any remaining
or upcoming perturbation. And so we draw
here that you can have this capacity
estimator close the loop and
start directing motor actions via active
inference in order to
follow this preference for resilience
against perturbation of the internal
milieu, which is then tied
to interceptive state estimation,
your other state estimate, your actual
sensory services and
this whole wiring diagram.
Speaker C: And maybe one thing just to add to
right, just to underscore a point is
that what I think if you go back one
slide here.
Speaker B: How this. Relates to the sort of
adaptive range of the settling point
too. And what I think is really
interesting about this, right, is that
you're not defining like when we started
out talking about how you might
traditionally think about set points for
allostasis in like a very traditional
thermostat model, right? What you're
talking about here is that there's
actually if the overall goal
of the brain. If the brain is
essentially there to help regulate and
adapt the sort of entire biological
system of the body to circumstances
outside of it that are constantly going
to be changing different challenges that
it's going to have to be responsive to.
Then you don't necessarily have a set
point. But you have a range where
the physiology can be most adaptable to
those perturbations and challenges.
Right? And so even just, I think to
simplify, I think that idea is
really at the core of what we're trying
to talk about regularly, that you
essentially want to have a
range where the physiology can be
adaptive. And you would imagine that if
the physiology is if some of these
parameters are pushed way far outside of
the center of that sigmoid, then you're
going to have a problem in that they
will not be able to adapt to
changes. You're not going to be able to
be at that linear point of maximum
stability if you're down here near the.
Speaker B: Threshold and you get some
random white noise that pushes you over
that threshold, obviously there isn't a
discrete catastrophic failure. But also,
obviously, you can no longer mount a
proportional response. Your body
is made of physical instruments which
have a limited range of responsiveness.
Speaker C: Yeah. And so our notion of allostasis to
say, when you can widen
the range of responsiveness rather than
narrowing it, or rather widen the range
of responsiveness when possible, while
narrowing the set of states or the
distribution of states that you actually
fall into look
like doing somewhat opposite things.
Speaker C: And so would it be the case, too right.
That you could have there's different
ways that you can have these systems
become sort of maladaptive if
that sigmoid becomes steeper and steeper
and steeper, where you basically have
just a very, very narrow range, where
you can actually have an adaptive
response. That can be one potential
problem. Another potential problem can
be when the sort of baseline level like
you're saying is pushed far outside of
that threshold, then also you're going
to require a lot more work and a lot
more control or a lot more control of
that system needed to really push it far
outside of that range. To actually adapt
to push it back. Really. To push it back
again. Yes. Which could cause other
problems downstream as well. Right, but
the point is just that the
sort of range that you want the system
to settle into is a range where it can
be adaptive to changes and prepare for
fluctuating sorts of circumstances,
right? Yeah. So I think
a good intuition to leave with,
since we are getting drawn towards the
end of the hour, is that if
you were to try to minimize interceptive
uncertainty, then what you might do is
just stay home all the time, your heart
rate will never vary too much up and
down. And we're living in the modern
world where you don't have to run away
from tigers. So why deal with the
uncertainty of going out and exercising,
or the perturbation of going out and
exercising? And what our notion of
allostasis here might tell you in reply
is to say when you go out and exercise,
the curve gets wider and so the adaptive
range where you can mount a proportional
response gets wider.
So go out and exercise because it
actually increases your resilience to
physiology, to future physiological
challenge. So it's still within the
active inference set of intuitions, but
we're really baking in this assumption
that you should preemptively prepare
yourself against possible challenge
rather than effective, rather than
acting to avoid possible challenge.
We've moved the handling of challenge
into the body.
Dean, go ahead.
Speaker A: As you get to those extremes of those
crisis moments, we talk about a little
bit about this in the Dot Zero. How does
the interplay or the instructional
proportion change between something
that's interactive and range seeking
to range reentering?
I'm curious if the normalisms change as
those extremes are reached because, as
you said, things don't always become
irreversibly catastrophically set
based on what you guys have obviously
looked at, what's your sense about how
that relationship between interaction
and instruction shifts as we get to
those really hard limits?
Speaker B: Jordan, you're often a little better on
physiology than me. Do you want to take
this? I'm not sure. I think you
might have it.
So let's see.
I'm honestly not so great on physiology
because I rely on Karen for it.
Speaker B: I would almost say that there's a map
territory failure here where we
were trying to model, so to speak,
normal function under normal
function, with that intuition about
resilience against challenge. And
there's several possible responses to an
extreme circumstance. One is that some
high up control mechanism can start
overriding these operating plant,
pushing them away from where they
normally are, and then that allows you
to deal with extreme circumstances
by no longer treating them as errors at
all. So, say if you're sick,
your core body temperature is modulated
upwards. That puts you in a fever state.
This is expensive metabolically, and it
feels bad compared to how you normally
function, but it should cook the germs.
And then when the extreme state, you
know, when that emergency is over,
supposedly, hopefully, usually you'll
be able to go back to normal function.
There are, of course, exceptions, such
as, say, Long Covet.
Speaker C: Right.
Speaker A: Just to make sure, though, do you see a
change in the amount of literally
commands and the amount of back and
forth as you approach those
limits?
Or do you think they kind of just
realize that they're getting closer and
closer to a fall off point?
Speaker B: I think that's actually an open and
empirical question. So one of the
reasons that we went as far as writing a
full mathematical model in this paper is
because there often there
isn't that much empirical, neuro
computational work on interception at
all. So if you ask very basic questions
like is interception
predictably coded below the neck?
That's still an open question.
It could be that peripheral and
terraceptors are just transducing a
stimulus signal, and then it's
only predictably encoded when it hits
the brain. We don't know yet. So we'd
rather have some.
Speaker D: Briefly lost eli, but okay,
while eli is rejoining. Okay, very
interesting. Different path through
the same material. Dave, if your
question is for Eli, we can wait a few
seconds. Not necessarily. I have
just a side comment. You don't
necessarily have to respond to this.
The discussion reminds me of two
different fallacies. One is the dark
room fallacy. If you want to minimize
it's a kind of a parody of active
inference if you don't want to be if you
don't want to be surprised and just stay
in a dark room where nothing changes,
which has been dismissed pretty
thoroughly by an active inference
activist. Also, there was a
fallacy, kind of a social Darwinist
tinged interoception of
the observation that every species has
a fixed number of heartbeats and
therefore valuable people, members of
Parliament and clergymen, should not
work because you're eating up your
lifetime, which of course isn't true,
because your heartbeats more slowly, so
it's stretched out more if you're in
good shape, right? But more relevant,
the steepness of the reflex curve. I
sometimes feel that folks working in
active inference cover maybe too
much with the notion of precision.
This is one quantity and it looks like
that slope in the blood pressure curve.
Is that something that would tend to be
covered by the term precision? And if
so, should that be approached in a more
differentiated way rather than just
being a single number that applies in
lots and lots of areas of control and
perception? That's interesting.
So normally the precision right, is
normally applied to the predictions. So
there's an idea of the precision of the
predictions being applied. And in this
case I think the idea is more of so
it comes back to where the preferences
being targeted in active inference
models and I think the slopes,
the response curve there is instead
trying to target that use of prior
preferences, right? So it's trying to
target specifically where is where
is the system trying to be navigated?
When people talk about prior
preferences, they've talked about it
sometimes in terms of the system
having strong precise priors
being encoded,
like April I prior to being encoded to
be targeted. And in this case, I think
we're trying to give an account of where
some of those fires can come from and
how these system and how opponent
processes or opponent chemicals
can help regulate the physiology and
we're trying to get a more natural
approach of where those can come about
from. But I
think.
Speaker D: If it is replaced. I'm just trying to
talk aloud to think through the
question. So if it is replacing
basically a prior preference,
and if normally
that prior preference would be handled
by a sort of precision
account of it, then to some extent the
steepness of that curve is trying to
tackle is somewhat of a replacement of
the precision. But yeah,
it's giving a different way of
maybe it is a replacement for the
precision. In that case. Eli's back so I
can try to answer your question. Eli,
do you want to complete your
presentation? Sure.
But just to answer the question, if
we're talking about the gain on one of
these sigmoid curves,
then yeah, that's sort of
a replacement for the precision, but
it's really thinking about it's thinking
about it the other way around.
So a variance quantifies your tolerance
for error, a precision or a
gain quantifies response to error.
Speaker D: Yes. So when you're talking about
purely sensory, these extra receptive
signals, the ones that aren't
prescribing references to you in any
way, then of course you want to save
the neural response, which is
metabolically expensive for precise
signals.
If you're talking about an internal
physiological curve, say,
reaction to a change in blood pressure,
then you want to try and make
the gain shallower. You want to tolerate
variance.
Sorry about getting my
home modem, I think just restarted
itself for no apparent reason. We call
that a sleep wake cycle.
Speaker B: Yeah, it's in some
sleep phase gradient. Updates, but it's
simpler. It's refreshed. It's ready for
you to complete the presentation
and then we'll return. Very interesting,
though.
Speaker B: Okay,
see share screen. Here we are.
Speaker D: All right, continue. Yeah. So now we
start getting into really what scant
visual material is available for section
four, which I think we'll have to go
over in detail in a more Q and A format
a little bit.
So if we then want to talk about how do
we integrate decision active inference
into this allostasis view, then we
can say decision making is this
notion of optimal control controls
subject to a set of expectations about
the future. So we'll
have to write an objective function.
And then we'll have our wiring diagram
back and we'll note that motor
references issued top down are
now conditioned upon or subject to
predictions about the future.
Then part of how we're going to get into
what this objective function is actually
made up of is
to first take the intuition that if we
start from neural circuits that can only
do predictive processing as we know it,
then one thing we can do with them is
simulate some ensemble or population
of potential state trajectories,
or really state action trajectories,
starting from some initial state.
Then given an objective function,
we can estimate the time average.
Given our ensemble,
we can turn that into feedback control.
Getting the stability in control theory,
the closed loop stability derived from
using feedback by then having a
recognition model. And then we can say,
ah, I'm going to update my
entire ensemble or population of
simulations by taking
them from the recognition model, which
is conditional upon observed sensory
outcomes,
and then having predictions from the
recognition density, which we're super
scripting here with SuperScript
parentheses two in comparison to
SuperScript parentheses one here.
We can then penalize a notion of
distance. So really we can penalize the
quote unquote size of the update in
information theoretic terms.
And if you've seen a free energy or an
expected free energy written out term by
term before, you should have seen one of
these. It's a KL divergence.
But what that gives us is feedback
stability control using stability
models. And that actually
gets to more or less the end of the
slides per se.
So as a few summary points,
our computational model gives us a
useful notion of affordance competition.
Basically run a bunch of forward
simulations, pick the ones that
are going to have good expected values
over time, averaging to actually enact
as motor references.
Speaker C: The. Sigmoidal curves after
we've taken their derivatives to convert
them to probability densities,
then taken the logarithm of those to
convert to log densities, which is much
more typical for active inference like a
log prior preference. Those actually
provide a notion of common currency
because now we've normalized all notion
of probability mass to one. So a
density over one variable and a density
over the other variable have the same
units. We don't need any more notion of
a reward currency in this model.
Then there's some encouragement for the
anatomists and physiologists to say hey,
let's go look at autonomic and visceral
motor regulation and see if we can
understand it in terms of these motor
control circuits at the low level.
And that just brings us to some very
overall conclusions.
Ideally our work should be placed in
dialogue with active inferences control
work by other authors and
of course acknowledgements. You can
really see here how much work went into
this on behalf of absolutely everyone in
the team and
references.
So I'll stop sharing and we can shift to
a more interactive format. Awesome,
well, thanks for sharing that. And so
where was that previously shared? In
what context?
Speaker B: Just in the context of our lab group.
Speaker D: Alright, cool. Psychology engineering
group your time. Yeah, so the slides
are really made for this like biologist
psychology with a few engineers group.
Speaker D: Cool. Okay. Well,
many ways, many paths to go.
Just kind of highlight a few pieces
under this broad umbrella of physiology.
One important point you raised was
how much homeostasis same
stasis is in effect versus
a mechanism of actually is that
stability sometimes empirically of
stasis and even allostasis that
underlaying by a drive to a set point
as it has been simplified or
understood as in that simple thermometer
model. And then to what extent do
we bring in allostasis hornesis arousal
and different physiological phenomena?
And consider these all part of just the
dynamic and multimodal homeostatic
engagements of complex bodies versus
discard, the old and with the new and
how much to lump and split physiology
when even at the single cellular life
form level they're engaging from a
computational or control or information
theoretic perspective in processes that
are analogous to some of these?
That's one point that we can explore.
Another area to explore is on
that theme of what are these systems
doing and how do we model it?
The map territory or the engineering
basic research question? We could
talk about a given physiological
process, body temperature stabilization
or the barrel receptor, the glucose and
so on. Is there the minimization
of a difference, for example, between
preferred and observed? Is there
a maximization of reward according
to some reward function?
Is there a maximization of precision?
Precision on what? Is there a
maximization of responsibility which
corresponds in the Sigmoidal curve
family to the linearized region.
Are there cases where all four of these
things are going to be happening
indistinguishably? Is there a case
where some of these phenomena are
occurring at the detriment of others?
Can we differentiate models and actually
make unique predictions, explanations
and control systems if we move
our emphasis from one of these
lenses to another lens?
And how should we think about different
physiological systems ranging from the
implicit and very ancient
mechanisms to those
which consciously may even feel like,
for example, error minimization, reward
maximization, precision maximization,
responsibility maximization.
So I'll pause there and either
authors may make some remarks or anyone
may raise a question or thought.
Speaker C: I wanted to ask you maybe just a direct
within this, because you talked at the
end about that. This gets us away
from having to have a reward currency.
Yeah, and maybe I'd be interested if you
can elaborate on that a little bit. So
just what would the typical role of
reward currency would be and how does
this sort of how does the framework that
you're proposing change that, right?
Speaker B: Yeah. So really I'd back off and say
what changes? This is the active
inference point of view, right?
Typically if you're doing something like
if you're someone like Yale Neve or Sam
Gershman, then you think about reward as
in a reinforcement learning terms as
something that the brain has to
maximize. And then you
would say, all right, well, I want the
uncertainty of my beliefs to be
minimized while I maximize reward.
So those are then two separate modular
computations that have almost opposite
goals. One of them is to minimize
uncertainty right now and the other is
to maximize reward over the long term
and income's active inference and really
says no, no. If you phrase this as
a variational optimization problem,
then you can get a unified objective for
this where the common currency is,
so to speak,
evidence, really evidence that you're
following the correct trajectory,
evidence that you're executing a
behavior correctly and evidencebased
in terms of, I guess we would call them
nats or bits are the units of
information theory. So if you're using e
as the basis of your logarithm,
then it's not if you're using a log to
base it's bits.
My dogs are getting picked up for their
walks.
Speaker D: Yes, this is a very interesting
complementary perspective where
we'll get reward maximization over time
when we increase our precision.
Now everybody agrees on that. And is it
gain to be the cart before the horse or
the horse before the cart? And which
one's the horse and which one's the
cart? And framing the unified
objective function in information
theoretic terms as a surprisal
founding heuristic, as has been done in
Bayesian evidence lower bounds for a
long time by framing surprise
minimization bounding as the unified
objective function and currency. Then
there is the realized maintenance
of homeostasis or however you want to
call that without needing a
traditionally structured maximization of
reward as defined by a reward or time
discounted reward function.
And it's also very interesting, like
we're not trying to accumulate body
temperature, we're not trying to
accumulate glucose. If we were playing a
game where simply more points were
better, like some social and subsocial
games, then a unilateral
optimization via maximization paradigm
makes a lot of sense. But for the kind
of physiological infinite games that we
play, as you highlighted with the
infinite horizon, then it may
make more sense to have a bounded
responsivity and an
emphasis on controllability under
inherited priors that those controllable
ranges are the survival ranges.
Otherwise how could one have existed for
generations rather than try to stack
up glucose?
Speaker B: Yeah. So I think it's always
really interesting to go back and read
Peter Sterling in this light because
beyond just the formal physiological
material. There are these stories that
he can tell of. For instance. People
living in longterm stressful situations
and they develop what we would now call
the diseases of civilization.
Which Sterling sort of implies
are the diseases of homeostasis living
too much the same too much of the time.
And indeed, speaking of not wanting to
stack up glucose,
this is an actual disease that happens
to people that is called diabetes.
It is considered a pathology. And so
there's almost an interesting misfit
between that intuitive notion of reward
or at least let's sneer slightly and say
that economic notion of reward which
has to be a form of accumulative wealth
in a common currency versus physiology,
in which too much of a good thing is
actually a bad thing, gain. Right.
And that actually comes back to.
Speaker A: Part. Of what this is contributing then.
Right, in one ways is a sort of shift in
metaphor. Right. I think
that point about an economic
conception of value and of reward is
it's useful to have a counterpoint to
that because as Eli is saying, there is
no other limit to economic reward,
there is a benefit to accumulating it.
If you think about sort of accumulating
capital to spend it in
this case, right. What we're focusing on
is how to basically
keep balanced and adaptable so that
future challenges can be actually
encountered and dealt with. And that
sometimes means packing light, not
keeping so much glucose on hand so that
you can deal with the reward or deal
with changing circumstances and adopt
them, but you can't.
It's actually been a pretty serious
problem to have this completely
abstracted notion of value that is
endlessly accumulative and.
Speaker B: Doesn'T. Interfere with any of the
biological realities of what systems
are actually doing. Right? Yeah.
Speaker C: It's so abstract that it's
going to have a really hard time
interfacing with biology. Yeah. Before
we go to the question, let's say let's
sum that up by saying bank accounts are
unbounded and they are useful because
they're unbounded like an economist
can conceive of trillions of dollars in
assets in a way that my
body cannot. Bodies are bounded,
they are physically bounded. They are
made of a finite amount of matter at
once. If you try to put too much more
into them, something bad will happen.
Speaker C: Actually, after setting us up on that
channel discussion, I've got a duck off
a little bit early, but I'm gain to try
to be back for 50.2 next week and I'm
really interested to see where this
conversation goes. I'll catch up on the
noise. Thank you. Alright, thanks.
Speaker B: If nobody minds, I'd like to ask Dave
his question first just because I was
about to when I got kicked off.
Speaker D: Yes. Go for it, Dave.
Speaker E: Is that one that I said? Yeah, I know
which one that was. If you have a new
question, is fine. Oh yeah, that's
probably better. Yeah, just to what
we were speaking of just now, the
diseases of civilization. There is the
rumor, and maybe this was just a fallacy
or misunderstanding, that people who
managed to stay in London during the
Blitz under conditions that you would
expect would produce massive amount of
psychosomatic disease, hysteria,
conversion syndromes, that it didn't
happen. People were just preposterously
state because they didn't have time to
be sick, they didn't have time to be
crazy. Did that really happen?
Did the sense of mission override what
otherwise would have been general stress
syndrome causing breakdowns?
Speaker B: Does someone know the detailed history
of the London Blitz in World War II?
Because I really don't. It's not english
1.5 journey for us to
explore, but to speak
to it generally. It's an interesting
question as well. To what extent by
comforting and regularizing we
even work against that and let alone
neglect other tradeoffs and incur
externalities dean.
Speaker A: This has been fantastic. So here's my
thing. Maybe in the
dot two we'll get into that I
mentioned at the end of the dot zero. I
was hoping you really had some really
velvet gloves to walk me through the 4.4
because and especially after the context
you've been able to provide us today
around the idea that engineers
and psychologists came into a room.
Now, I don't know if that once you got
into that room, it became an
intersection with red light, green light
and you guys kind of played a red rover,
come on over thing or whether you know
it so well. Here's the thing, because I
actually did work with CFOs and
engineers and so what you discover
is there's a bit of an isomorphist I
want to be able to diagram this out for
you view that has to be biased for
engineers and then there's the spatially
enveloped view of the psychologist,
right? Like they're in their
phenomenological space. And what you've
done is you've tried to say when
those two worlds come together, I don't
know if it's a collision, I don't know
if it's cooperation. It's a variety of
things, right? It's complicated we'll
just leave it there. But my question is
this as I got to 4.4, it felt
like if I was skiing I went from a
beautiful powder field to some sparsely
disturbance trees to tighter and tighter
and finally I was like, I don't know how
it's going to keep going because there
doesn't seem to be any more gaps here.
It's just getting too tight for me. And
the reconciliation, like when you're
skiing as a metaphor is you're not
looking at the trees, you're looking at
the nonsense, the non objects. It's a
reconciliation. And when we're talking
about dodgeball as your metaphor or
whether we're talking about glucose
control, these to me what you were
describing up until that point was
essentially you were saying for us to
know what's going on, we're gain to look
at the risk management, we're going to
look at the coordination, we're going to
look at those things that are
essentially backwards facing. We can say
that in order for the process to carry
forward, to continue, there has to be
some addressing of those factors and
then there has to be the reconciliation.
Just like when the engineers and the
psychologists are proximal to one
another, it's an entanglement and it's
not the engineers get to tell the
psychologists what to do any more than
the psychologists get to tell the
engineers what to do. Right? So if
the behavioral piece, if the idea of the
biology and the physiology is if I do
this now in real terms,
I have to look at that. And you guys had
an L, four different time frames,
right? I can manage that. You spoke
clearly to that. I read that and
it was clear to me I can coordinate
that. Again, that was very, very clear.
And then I got the four four and I
simply lost the thread because
what I was looking for was the
reconciliation. I will align this next
move with the range recapitulator.
That's what I was expecting next. And
then so I went, okay, so where is the
strategy? Because that's there when
psychologists and engineers get into a
room, they don't just abandon their
strategy. It comes with them. It follows
them into that space and carries them to
that question of I reconcile an
advantage and all of the above until I
choose this choice while I was keeping
all of the above. So you guys talked
about that in other parts of it. You
said we can't just abandon it. But I
couldn't understand how the formalism
reconciled it. So I'm sorry that's such
a long winded question but your paper
always spend 6 hours of my life
going, these guys have got to be much
closer to answering this because I've
never been able to answer it. But then I
got lost and I just felt like, oh man,
what am I missing?
Speaker B: Okay, so I'm going to disappoint
you slightly and say what you're missing
is. That.
Speaker B: I think what's missing from our writing
is really being clear that we're working
under a very unusual set
of constraints in how we formulated this
model. So specifically,
unlike, say, Sam Gershman or Yale Neve,
or unlike the literature on deep active
inference in computers, we're assuming
that you essentially don't need an
extra set of computational ingredients
for reinforcement learning.
So we're saying, assuming that you can
do only the computational
operating point to be involved in
predictive processing, what can you come
up with that will handle a control
problem? And the answer is this
very specific thing with these nastily
involved derivations called pathogen
control. And you'll notice
that when I was gain over those slides,
I basically said, let's just say you can
simulate possible futures,
like possible episode length courses
of future activity, and you
can evaluate them in terms of your
objective function, and then
you can update them by means of a
recognition model or by integrating
prediction error and using predictive
coding. Then how do we
build a formalism out of just those?
And the upside is that this does let us
look at the controls literature and say,
alright, this is actually optimal
feedback stabilized control.
We can look at some of the bounded
rationality literature in cognitive
science and neuroscience and say our
objective function is a free energy.
That is, if you have to penalize
how much you change neural firing over
time, or how much you change your mind
and update your beliefs over time
because you only have so much metabolic
power in your head, then we include a
penalty term for that.
And we can say, this can all just be
done by embodied simulation and
reference configuration motor control.
Does that mean this is how the brain
actually does things? Of course not.
It does mean that if you want to do your
modeling with I think Andy
Clark tends to quote Quine and say,
if you have a taste for desert
landscapes, then we've given you
a computational model that is basically
just sand and rocks. And as such,
yes, it's something of a hostile
environment.
Walk without rhythm. You won't attract
the worm.
Speaker D: In the planes of octaves.
Speaker B: If you live behind the shield wall where
we have state estimate
value objective function. Good for you.
Speaker D: In the stretched sigmoid with broad
variability. So stretched that it is
flat and plain like, but still highly
controller within large bounds. That's
where we're oscillating. Yeah,
very interesting. It'll be,
I think, great in our lab to pick
up a few points. From am I the one
cutting out again? I still see
you. It's okay.
Speaker A: Yeah, you're back. All right. You
flickered a bit. Okay. In the
last minutes, we can talk
about some ideas from earlier in the
paper. Look at any of the figures, and
then in the dot two. That will be
awesome to really approach the formalism
and help Dean on that ski journey.
What would be something to go to in
these last minutes.
Justine. Maybe I'll
be able to get a chance to elaborate
with a bit more with Jordan in the next
one. But I'm curious.
You took gain at Great Lakes to say,
look, this doesn't map directly on
to all the complexities that we know
exist, because you said you started this
in 2019, you had a bit of time on your
hands and then did kind
of allude to this at the beginning.
Were there discoveries that you made
that you didn't anticipate? Because you
were very also very respectful in who
you acknowledged as sort of laying the
groundwork here. You had a bit of
stability to work off of,
but did you find yourself introduced,
being introduced to things that weren't
there prior to you guys coalescing
around this? And do you think it
continues to evolve or does it just stay
on a theoretical level?
Speaker B: Actually, I'd say for me personally,
the big unanticipated discovery was just
how little we know about interceptive
neuroanatomy and neurophysiology, and I
mean in the periphery. So our
lab with Lisa and Karen, lisa handles
the stuff above the neck. And so we've
got Barrett and Simmons 2015. There's a
number of other good papers saying
essentially you look at the brain
architecture and it looks like, at least
in cortex, the interceptive and visceral
motor cortices are fairly central to the
architecture. And then you ask, okay,
so what kinds of signals are coming in
from the periphery to then be subjected
to predictive processing in cortex?
And you basically get told, well,
interceptive signals, obviously.
So there was that moment when I was
working with Karen and realized, oh,
okay, so it looks like there's actually
this close analogy that we could
hypothesize between the known
function of a somatomotor
circuit for voluntary motor control
and this way of handling barrel reflex
function. And it looks like for the
barrel reflex, you can voluntarily
change the gain or the tolerance, those
being inverse model each other.
Changing the operating point voluntarily
doesn't seem to happen, but it does seem
to shift. And it does begin to look as
though, ah, we can just we can stop just
saying, you know, there are
interceptive signals, we don't know
anything about them, right? And instead
ask, how could we break down the
autonomic nervous system and
the interoception periphery into these
control circuits, where there's a
reference that flows from above or is
possibly built in as a prior and then a
sensor and then a motor neuron or an
effector?
Speaker D: Again, total speculating.
One can imagine that loop could be ultra
local or even get cellular
electrical junction. So as local as
could be to close the motor control
loop, and then there would be
potentially a more measles scale purely
within the periphery, maybe some sort of
motor coordination or vasoconstriction
type actions that are being enacted
through local neural networks and other
systems. And then when you got to make
the call to the. Central nervous system
and engage at that level.
It's the highest capacity of like inner
modal memory computation,
all these other complex phenomena which
then can be seen to have their rightful
place maybe even in a specific brain
region. But the entire integrated
Dodgeball performance is not
going to be located to a brain region
any more than it would be located to a
fingertip because it all needs to be
coordinated and not every call can
be local and not every call can be
global. So finding out how bodies as
territories and our models as maps
wire things up is
going to make models that are more
interpretable, better aligned with
empirical data, making more useful
predictions and explanations. Very
interesting angle. And I would say
just to piggyback a little, you know,
as a modeling paradigm, I think this is
one of the real strengths of active
inference is that once you're dealing
with these probability densities and log
probability densities, you are
able to start sketching out these
hierarchical structures. And that
doesn't mean that every hierarchical
active internal model is automatically a
map of the nervous system, but it does
mean that you have a language that is at
least minimally capable of expressing
what we so abundantly find in the
empirical evidence.
Speaker D: Yeah, one part of the paper that
was very interesting, we in
reading it, remarked how although most
papers are written in words, this one
was very wordforward. Each section
had a preamble content
summary sandwiching technique, as did
the paper. At a higher scale, the
nomenclature was upfront and clear and
then the relationship between the
cumulative distributions and the
classical PDF type probability densities
was made clear. But this
exactly connects something
that has a,
in the generic case, a guaranteed
inflection point interpretable
thresholded values. This is why Sigmoid
functions are used as activation
functions in artificial neural networks
with an optimizable
Laplacian approximation like
inverted quadratic form that
is able to be used as a log probability.
And so really. Like. Especially with
figure nine showing the stepwise
relationship opens the door
to like hey. If you've seen a Sigmoid
somewhere. Now you can think about that
as like a PDF hiding a PDF bell curve
and then where you have seen a Gaussian
or bell curve or Laplacian
approximation. You can go the other
direction and think about that in
terms of a Sigmoidal response action.
And so they're rarely connected.
So clearly though, those with
familiarity, it's almost the water that
they swim in and those without
familiarity wouldn't see the connection
and the challenge and the opportunity is
like to stick in the middle and stay in
the connection space to raise
attention to some of these
relationships. Which again, otherwise
you could have a whole subfield of
physiology working on the Sigmoid
response curve and a whole subfield of
hierarchical predictive processing
models working in the PDF space or log
PDF space. And it's just a derivative
and a log or an exponentiation and a
derivation away from
those two fields being formally
connected, not just as like a
speculative review paper, someone could
or should do this, but it's done. We
just didn't know.
Cool. So I think regarding the writing,
I really have to hand credit to Lisa and
Karen for a lot of things where speaking
of more, speaking of dialectical
processes, we have a very simple writing
dialectic on these papers, which is
junior author knows math. Senior authors
did not specialize in math in their
undergrad or master's degree or even
PhD, however good they are with it now.
And the result ends up being you're
always told to go back and explain every
single step. And of course, Jordan,
who was here before, was helping a lot
with the writing and the structuring and
the sign posting. And then I
think the actual insight that you can
take one of these sigmoids and turn it
into a PDF I think came after hammering
our heads on some of the embodied
predictive processing literature a bunch
of times because
it is one of those things that is
literally embodied.
Speaker A: Dean yeah, I just wanted
to get this in. What attracted
me to the paper in the first place was
the allostasis and the interception.
What kept me going back to it was and
we talked about this in the dot zero was
wayfinder, that rule perspective
swaps versus a way finder.
When I first state reading this paper,
I saw the metamorphosis from
identifying a way to find things.
And now after having this conversation
with you today and Jordan and of course
the usual suspects. It's clearer
to me that this paper is trying to play
that role of being wayfinder
prospective identifier as opposed
to we found our way
or this is our way to solve all
the world's ills. Which of course I
don't think it was ever your intention.
But when you pull things that are
seemingly quite far apart. Like
allostasis and interception.
I get excited. But as you pointed out,
pump the brakestem, don't get too
excited here. We're doing the best we
can. So on that level,
my Amygdala is still functioning
correctly. In our
closing thoughts with a driving example.
Are we accumulating speed or minimizing
the amount of time? Or are speed limits
even set as exteriorized norms
and stigmaergic marks on the niche such
that a variety of cars from a sports car
to 18 wheeler can be within a zone of
optimal controllability, taking into
account the presence of crosswalks and
so on. And so alongside as
we think about what we want to explore
in the dot two alongside diving into
formalisms. Trying to do some
excavation and interoception on
how and where the economic
optimization as maximization is
implicitly used and where
some of these other notions that
were being raised without needing to
be polemical or replace value
maximization. But where we can see
these other survivability criterion
has potentially different decompositions
of unified objective function that are
informational and so on. I think that's
going to be quite far ranging because
there's more situations I would venture
where we would rather have
controllability and exteroception
bounding and meeting rather than
point stacking. So final
comments you like?
Speaker B: Yeah, so I just really want to close by
reemphasizing that.
I think I have this joke on my Twitter
profile, "Abolish the value function!" And
that's really just a pun for the people
who can get it, but we're not trying to
tell people, contrary to their
subjective experience, oh, you don't
really have value in your brain.
There's actually just, you know, trying
to track your reference trajectory.
So in the plant two, we can talk about
which specific kinds of feedback
control, what kinds of feedback
mechanisms are really being spoken of in
this paper. And I think
as preview,
it's negative, both negative in the
sense of avoiding negative reinforcement
and in the sense of trying to flatten
out a response function and be able to
proportionally respond. So, you know,
with the benefit of hindsight, this
paper is going to have a pretty limited
domain of application,
but it's helpful in that it gives us a
language to turn around to the
empiricists and say, this is what we
want to actually look for.
Speaker D: Any closing comments? Otherwise that's a
great noise. Well,
Eli and Jordan as well, thanks for
coming out and for engaging in dot
oneery and we'll see you next week.
Speaker A: Thanks, guys. See you next week.